um so what's going on I know you got the
new record that just dropped uh the the
Blick record obviously no statements is
going crazy it's a album on the way
what's what's happening with the
project yo Blick is out right
now but we got a remix coming top of the
Year who's on the remix I can't tell you
that the way you just looked over there
was like should I say cuz I was like
even confused if I was able to say that
like
what's this Snoop saying that huh who we
got a we got a remix droper top of the
year with your favorite rapper Who's my
favorite rapper I'm curious if you
know I don't know who's your favorite
rapper but just know he's your favorite
rapper Who's on the record I can't tell
you I'mma tell you after the interview
I'mma wh what city are they from I can't
say that cuz then you going to know I
won't know unless they're unless they're
from Charlotte and it's the baby the
dirtiest part of the
trenches what state can't tell you y I'm
not going to let them figure it out from
[Music]
Chicago Chicago shout out to Chief Keef
though it's not Chief
Keef could it be is he from Chicago yeah
all right good could it be little Dirk
no but I [__] with little Dirk man shout
out to Little Dirk I hope we we get a
song dirtiest part of the trenches
Southern trenches Northern trenches the
dirtiest part oh nasty nasty just the
Chester
Pennsylvania have you ever been to
Chester Pennsylvania it's it's not good
but look so we got Blick coming the
remix the remix with a visual with a
visual then we got a EP coming okay can
we talk about it yeah what's up when the
EP coming the ep's coming
next year I mean obviously it's
December the EP is coming next year okay
and the EP is called scars and Stripes
oh I like that lots of
features stuck
with you just can't tell me okay I can't
tell you shout out to my grand mom I
didn't wear a bracelet today every time
I wear my gom's bracelet it means I'm
going to be protected and she's with me
that's dope I uh my dad has a godmother
I don't have one I don't know do you
have like is your godmother still with
us she's alive oh she's alive good for
her [__] I got to ask I don't know are
you like have a good relationship with
her I love my God Mom so much she's like
my second mom you know uh in uh like uh
where I'm from in Arizona there a lot of
uh you know obviously my son's half
Mexican and uh I noticed that a lot
of uh my wife's and my baby Mama's
Family they'll pick someone as The
Godfather or the godmom and then they
end up beefing with them weird and then
it's like they're just like Gone With
the Wind it's like oh yeah that's your
godfather but [__] him you know can I
say something I feel like God moms don't
really get appreciated a lot you feel me
cuz it's like they're literally for you
when your mom is not there like my mom
you would hope so of course yeah yeah
well my godom yeah she's like there like
as a mom and she just hold a lot of like
baggages for me you feel me like so she
stepped in and held it down for she
stepped in yeah that's dope that's good
shout out to God Mom man um who would
you okay how about this right now
there's I I my my two favorite movements
going on in newor New York are you and
the uh 41 the 41 kids uh I love those
guys man and and shout out to Jen she's
she's killing it um have you guys worked
together or you guys I feel like it'd be
dope if you guys did some [__] together
y i I love they they they so lit and
they're so positive they're just having
fun they ain't on no [__] like yeah
they just Good Vibes you know what I
mean and like we if we work that's going
to be
amazing yeah if we work if we work we
was in the booth and [__] we we played
some [__] that's good yeah who's uh
who's your like
uh bucket Le bucket list feature that
hasn't happened yet cuz you've already
worked with Snoop and I mean You' I mean
that that's a big deal oh that's the
realest [__] Snoop Dog the realest the
realest [__] like you don't even know
that [__] put me look he jumped on my
song yo Snoop Dog is the realest [__] M
he jumped on my song he brought me out
to you did you go did you go to his
compound in uh Englewood look yeah he
jumped on my song No I know he brought
me out to the Yankee stadium for free no
charge and he did it with no hesitation
[__] be funny with that [__] what do
you mean he brought you like to perform
with him at Yankee Stadium yeah he
brought me out to perform I love Snoop
Dog bro dead ass that's my [__] in real
life and he's also the same we don't got
to talk every day just for me to right
[__] with a [__] you know what I mean
like he was just a fan like how did he
even find out I don't I'm a fan but he
just loves my song this is New York
actually what happened was I dm' him yo
listen this the LA this is La all I do
is DM people I just be dming these
[__] the people that I don't think I
would ever even be able to work with
right I be like you know what let me
just try and you got to take a shot
everybody think they you would not
imagine listen bro the people you would
not imagine I got songs with is the ones
I got songs with because you dm' them
just because I dm' them I think most
artists have like too much ego to like
want to reach out it's like bro just
shoot your shot like bro I'm talking
about [__] you watch you be like I
would never be able to get that that's
fire so that's how it happened with
Snoop was a DM yep just sliding in a DM
listen artist if you hungry enough you
want to make it your biggest resource is
your DMs I know you didn't uh you don't
smoke weed but um you didn't smoke with
Snoop oh no I didn't smoke with Snoop
yet there's a few guys like I smoke with
Snoop I don't smoke but for Snoop Dog I
I feel like snoop's one of the few guys
who like if they pass you the joint
you're like I mean [__] it it's Snoop I
know his [__] goingon to have me Zed up